salut bienvenue dans ce troisième
épisode des interviews à la table
aujourd'hui je reçois un âne Godefroy on
a l'impression d'être un vieil animateur
mais comment je parle anago froid je
l'ai invité parce qu'elle est
hypernésique et c'est une particularité
du cerveau de sa mémoire en l'occurrence
qui est très rare dont on n'a pas
beaucoup le casion de parler il y a
beaucoup d'idées reçues sur
l'hypermnésie on va pas faire le tour de
ce syndrome là de l'hypermnésie parce
que on est pas spécialiste du sujet par
contre elle est spécialiste d'elle-même
et donc ça va être intéressant de savoir
comment elle pense ça comment elle
ressent ça comment elle vit ça bienvenue
dans ce troisième interview à la dame
si je t'invite aujourd'hui c'est parce
que tu es hyper
rare d'ailleurs on va en parler mais le
but de ces interviews c'est de savoir
aussi comment tu penses les choses
comment tu ressens les choses tu vois
au-delà que traiter une hypermnésie
d'ailleurs on va même pas parler
vraiment de l'hypermnésie on va parler
de ton hypermnésie à toi ce qui est sur
moi un peu différent je le disais Rohff
il y a sûrement des degrés là-dedans etc
et on ne veut pas que tu sois porte
parole de l'hypernésie en France et pas
le but du jeu tu vois mais c'est trop
tard
tu sais que on a comptabilisé qu'une
centaine de personnes en France non dans
le monde j'ai dit en France non dans le
monde dans le monde dans l'univers j'ai
toujours dire plus non dans le monde une
certaine de personnes dans le monde
c'est très rare mais qui sont pas
détectés
diagnostiqué ça c'est possible l'idée
c'était que tu racontes ce que c'est de
vivre avec ça et peut-être commencer par
le définir qu'est-ce que l'hypermnésie
un algot 3 alors pour toi selon toi
selon tes termes c'est une mémoire qui
est plus développée que la moyenne donc
en tout cas ce que j'ai moi ce que je
ressens c'est qu'elle est vachement plus
développée et je m'en suis rendu compte
en fait je me rendais compte que je
retenais beaucoup plus de choses que les
autres et notamment des choses très
anecdotiques donc par exemple on va me
dire un truc et je vais pouvoir le
ressortir à la personne et la personne
va même pas se souvenir avoir 17 choses
et je me suis souvent demandé mais enfin
pourquoi pourquoi ça sur moi parce que
du coup j'ai l'impression aussi que
j'accordais beaucoup d'attention aux
gens et qu'en retour je l'avais pas
forcément une espèce de frustration de
d'accord donc plus ça l'intérêt c'est
pas lui il s'en fout mais moi je me
souviens de ça sur lui machin et tout et
puis un jour ben j'ai fait un test en
fait de QI et c'est là qu'on m'a qu'on
m'a détecté cette hypernésie et en fait
ça m'a vachement aidé à comprendre
que j'avais un truc un peu différent et
du coup ça m'a vachement fait
relativiser sur le sujet quoi ça t'a
permis en fait de mieux comprendre ses
relations aux autres
moi c'est pour l'anniversaire c'est un
truc très bizarre mais c'est les dates
d'anniversaire je les parfaitement bien
que ça peut être mes amis ça peut être
des célébrités je le lis une fois je les
retiens toi ma banquière une fois m'a
dit qu'il était née le 31 janvier je
m'en souviens alors que je l'ai vu
qu'une fois dans ma vie ce genre de
choses et je comprenais pas pourquoi moi
je souvenais des anniversaires de tout
le monde et que parfois on pouvait
oublier le mien c'est tout con mais ça
pouvait que c'est ils apparaissent
comment tu es souviens ils apparaissent
très clairs
et ouais les vêtements ou les choses que
les personnes ont dites la phrase exacte
souvent et du coup quand on remet en
cause ma parole aussi je suis très
frustrée parce qu'au des fois on peut
pas vérifier
au-delà de persuader tu sais je sais je
suis sûr je suis certaine parce que
c'est obligé de sûrement à faire un
travail sur toi des fois de lâcher prise
moi c'est pour une broutille
on va pas s'engueuler pour ça donc on va
dire si la raison au cas la raison
je sais pas si c'est vie mais du coup
c'est possible est-ce que tu arrives à
sélectionner ce dont tu veux souvenir ou
c'est impossible j'en parlais avec un de
mes potes quand je lui racontais ce que
j'avais et tout il m'a dit ok du coup
tel jour tu m'enverras une photo de
frites vraiment il voulait me tester
donc il me dit 10 janvier tu m'envoies
une photo de fringues donc moi je suis
ok donc je le note pas et tout il
m'envoie la veille t'as pas oublié
quelque chose et là je m'énerve je dis
ouais je lui dis mais en fait c'était
demain je dis tu vois j'avais pas oublié
machin et ça m'agace parce que du coup
je me suis trouvé que je me souvenais tu
vois donc ça par exemple je me suis
quand il m'a dit 10 janvier tu m'envoies
une photo de fric bah je me suis je me
suis souvenu là il m'a demandé de lui
envoyer une photo de Roselyne Bachelot
le 2 mars par exemple il la recevra
est-ce que par contre il est chiffre
temps tu les retiens facilement est-ce
qu'il y a des catégories que tu retiens
mal genre je m'étais dit peut-être une
les couleurs une époque où juste il y a
un truc que je retiens très mal c'est
c'est horrible en plus c'est quand je
vois des gens que j'ai pas vu depuis
longtemps et tout et qui me disent
qu'ils font dans la vie après quand je
vais avec telle personne qui va me dire
il fait quoi lui dans la vie voilà parce
que je il y a aussi ce problème ou quand
j'écoute quelqu'un que je parle à
quelqu'un je ne décroche je voudrais bon
je ne décroche très facilement et quand
c'est pas mes amis proches ma famille et
tout mais j'ai un problème un peu avec
ça avec ce côté-là de l'exactitude tu
vois de propos donc en catégorie c'est
vrai que ce que font les gens dans la
vie j'ai un peu de mal alors que si tu
les avais vu exercer peut-être que le
fait d'avoir le souvenir épisodique de
ce moment là tu vois il faudrait que tu
t'emmène au travail il faut que tu
fasses une journée avec c'est ça mais je
me rends compte même mes amis je sais
globalement ce qu'ils font mais c'est
vrai que j'ai un peu de c'est
globalement
à quel âge tu as commencé à t'apercevoir
que tu étais différente sans pour autant
savoir exactement ce que tu avais très
jeune pour le coup je me suis vite rendu
compte que j'avais en tout cas pour la
mémoire que j'avais quelque chose de en
plus ou de différent parce que je me
rappelle je me donnais des défis toute
seule et je me rappelle encore d'un truc
que je m'étais dit quand j'étais toute
petite je m'étais dit je me rappelle de
cette phrase quand je serai grand-mère
et de juste cette phrase que je dis là
donc je me rappellerai quand je serai
grand et je me je sais que je me donnais
des filles toutes seules du coup je me
souviens encore de cette phrase je me
souviens de quand je l'ai dit à quel
endroit c'est bizarre mais j'ai vite
vite vu que j'ai j'avais une manière de
penser même au-delà de la mémoire assez
différente enfin j'étais un peu aussi
j'étais pas du tout dans je vais me dire
dans mon monde oui mais sans m'exclure
des autres mais ouais j'ai eu vite vu
que je fonctionnais différemment et
c'est comme si aussi plus jeune je
voulais être différente un peu est-ce
que tu me disais ok j'ai un super
pouvoir faut que je me déteste ou est-ce
que tu voulais être aussi en externe
c'est à dire être considéré comme
quelqu'un qui avait un petit plus ou
alors est-ce que tu t'essaies de
t'adapter je pense que c'était un peu
les deux ouais mais
j'ai vite ouais je sentais qu'il y a un
truc qui fonctionnait un peu
différemment chez moi sans non plus être
complètement à côté de la plaque et
j'étais moi j'ai toujours été plutôt
bien intégré et tout mais ouais je pense
que c'est un petit mix des deux tu vois
quand tu te détectes particularité quand
tu es petit tu veux parfois la gâcher
pour pas être sortie du dos
après tu faisais partie des 100 il
permetit du monde
ça m'étonne c'est peu quoi
seul parce que je pense qu'il y a des
gens qui sont hypernique déjà qui ne le
savent pas et tu disais il y a plusieurs
types c'est sûr et il y en a c'est on
retient vraiment tous les jours dans
notre vie et moi je suis pas du tout à
ce niveau là quoi oui c'est un trouble
qui est même considéré un certain stade
comme une maladie ouais parce que ça
devient incapacité d'oubli qui est
terrifiante et qui te fait tourner en
boucle mais ça on y reviendra d'ailleurs
sur pour comment ça fonctionne et
comment toi tu le tu le prennes comment
tu le ressens c'était quoi au moment où
toi tu dis ok je suis je suis une
Superman de la mémoire apparemment je me
souviendrai de mettre ça quand je serai
grand-mère mais en même temps qu'est-ce
que tu penses de la mémoire des autres à
ce moment-là est-ce que tu dis ils ont
une mémoire normale est-ce que tu te dis
pauvre douche tu vois c'est est-ce que
tu l'es vu est-ce que pas du tout en
fait avant d'être détecté je me disais
ils sont pas attentifs à moi autant que
je suis attentif à eux mais une fois que
j'ai été détecté j'ai compris que oui
ils avaient juste une mémoire normale et
que moi n'était un peu plus je sais pas
si je peux dire développer mais un peu
plus haute que notre fonctionnement en
tout cas voilà et donc comme j'ai su
qu'en fait je vais pas dire que c'était
moi le problème mais que c'était moi qui
avait un petit particularité tout de
suite ça va un peu déjà aider à
relativiser et nous il y a aucun
jugement je me dis juste bah ils ont une
mémoire normale moi je le vis pas trop
mal mais des fois plus chiant parce que
beaucoup d'infos tout le temps
se souvenir de tout enfin c'est un peu
un peu lourd après c'est pratique pour
certaines choses mais du coup je me dis
enfin tout le monde me dit par exemple
oh la chance et je leur dis souvent
attention parce que c'est pas pas
forcément que du couple là tu vois on
considère plutôt comme un trouble que
comme un bénéfice à la base parce que
effectivement le la particularité de
l'hypermnésie c'est pas de retenir plein
de choses puisque le cerveau est fait
pour retenir en fait et donc il stocke
l'information mais il a déconnecte du
système si elle n'est pas immédiatement
utile ou qu'il a considère pas utiliser
dans le temps et toi tu es un manquement
de ce niveau là donc c'est pas un truc
en plus effectivement ça manquement il
fait que du coup à l'inverse ces
informations vont te revenir sans avoir
demandé la récupération de l'information
en fait c'est pas tant effectivement se
souvenir de tous et surtout ne pas
oublier en fait c'est un peu le la
différence il y avait un exercice qui
était proposé aux États
d'une engueulade qu'ils avaient eu avec
quelqu'un ils passera mieux vaut chez à
cause d'une petite engueulade il y a
trois ans
en leur proposait de l'écrire sur un
bout de papier de le brûler pour déjà se
symboliser en fait l'effacement il
l'oublie tu vois pour envoyer des trucs
est-ce que toi il y a des choses comme
ça de
broutille mais vraiment des broutilles
qui font que des années après ça va tu
t'entends avec la personne mais dans le
fond toi tu sais que c'est pas toi qui
avait pris la bouteille de lait en fait
je démonte pas enfin après j'ai jamais
eu je pense de grosses grosses
engueulade comme ça mais c'est vrai que
je me rappelle d'un anecdote mais nulle
tu vois l'émission déco de Valérie
damino un jour je me suis rendu compte
que des échos ça faisait d'amido et
compagnie je m'en suis rendu compte
toute seule et je le dis à ma sœur moi
je découvre aujourd'hui du coup voilà
c'est incroyable c'est fantastique et je
le dis à ma sœur et genre on en reparle
15 jours après et il me fait ah mais oui
mais c'est moi qui te l'ai dit et là je
fais un an et j'ai maintenu vraiment du
début à la fin je fais non c'est moi qui
t'ai dit machin machin et les deux on
était pas d'accord sauf que moi je
savais je me souvenais du moment où je
elle l'a aujourd'hui tu peux être sûr
qu'elle a complètement oublié cette
anecdote parce que c'était vraiment
quand c'était diffusé déco donc j'ai pas
2008 peut-être ou un truc comme ça mais
c'est un exemple tout con ou pour te
dire tu vois je m'en souviens encore
aujourd'hui quoi alors que c'est c'est
ridicule ouais mais tu as pas le choix
non j'ai pas le choix mais c'est
terrifiant parce qu'en plus le dans le
fonctionnement naturel de la mémoire
donc pour les autres on va dire il y a
la création de Foss souvenirs et donc
cette création là c'est ce qui s'est
passé pour ta soeur elle s'est écrit un
faux souvenir dans sa tête dont elle va
être intimement persuadée qu'il est vrai
alors que au fond d'elle elle sait qu'il
lui manque avant le milieu après qu'il
est un peu bizarre ce souvenir mais je
l'ai vécu moi-même j'ai vécu un faux
souvenirs qui est incroyablement dense
et la seule manière d'admettre que c'est
pas vrai c'est parce que mon agenda me
montre que j'étais pas à Paris au moment
de se souvenir là et ça souvenir que je
raconte comme si j'étais là et je sais
que j'étais là mais en fait dans le fond
si je le creuse un peu je vois bien
qu'il a un peu diffus qui manque des
éléments pour le comprendre et je pense
que elle c'est ça qu'elle a qu'elle a dû
vivre par contre ce qui est marrant
c'est que
quand vous avez eu cette engueulade elle
savait pour ta mémoire non elle savait
pas
si longtemps c'était en octobre 2021 ah
oui c'est extrêmement récent non non
elle savait pas mais par contre ils ont
toujours vu ils ont tout compris ma sœur
quand elle me demandait
ah c'est quand déjà l'anniversaire de
telle copine à ma sœur ouais
je fais Aurélie c'est le 10 puisque
marine c'est le 11 et c'est même pas mes
copines
donc elle a ils ont toujours vu toujours
su que j'avais une très bonne mémoire
mais on n'avait pas encore bien au
dessus quoi
aujourd'hui dans ton travail parce que
je me dis que c'est pas si évident que
attends de souvenirs de plein de trucs
du passé égal retenir ses cours d'un
claquement de doigts ou ses chroniques
d'un claquement d'eau bah non c'est pas
pareil tu vois souvent on dit quand je
fais un peu de passage sur scène on dit
bah c'est facile pour toi de retenir ton
texte je dis bah c'est pas la même chose
quoi en plus je raconte des histoires
mais comme je raconte des histoires qui
me sont arrivées mais je les écris donc
il faut mettre les bonnes vannes au bon
moment donc c'est pas toujours facile il
y a une fois où ça va vraiment aider à
l'école c'est que j'étais au bac
d'histoire et la veille de l'épreuve je
lis en fait dans le manuel un chapitre
qu'on avait pas vu en cours et qui était
susceptible de tomber au bac je me dis
bon bah je vais le lire je lis une fois
la page 2 fois je veux quand même comme
ça et puis le lendemain c'était un
croquis la fin une carte qu'il fallait
faire et enfin il fallait la remplir en
fait et je me dis mais attends je vais
pouvoir faire quand même un argumentaire
à côté et j'ai fait toute une partie en
fait grâce à la page que j'avais lu la
veille que j'avais en tête j'avais je
voyais la page dans ma tête donc ça m'a
aidé cette fois-ci ce que j'ai eu 18 au
bal de l'histoire moi qui avait 6 toute
l'année enfin 8 après pour les cours
j'étais pas une élève j'étais assez
moyenne moi je pense que là ça détruit
aussi une idée reçue et c'est peut-être
bien d'ailleurs que tu es pas été
diagnostiqué trop tôt parce que
peut-être que Aurélie des attentes par
rapport à ça tu vois de les pays qui se
font détectés HPI tu vois et qu'après on
attend deux d'être intelligent
professionnel en tout cas de santé qui
t'a diagnostiqué il permet les éclates
un test de cuite avec quel âge parce
qu'on sait pas donner là j'avais 23 ans
parce que là j'ai 25 ans j'avais 23
c'était une femme d'octobre 2021 du coup
tu vois je me souviens de la date et
c'était un test au départ de cuit
classique j'ai testé c'est je lui ai en
fait quand elle m'a testé sur ma mémoire
elle était impressionnée parce qu'en
fait elle m'a fait un test avec des
chiffres ou à me donner plein de films
de chiffres il fallait donner dans
l'autre sens dans le machin et tout ah
bah là j'étais j'étais à 100% quoi elle
était impressionnée sur le moment
ensuite je sors pendant 15 minutes pour
qu'elle fasse un peu le bilan machin et
quand elle quand elle m'explique le
résultat elle fait donc là
QI mémoire vous avez je ressent 37 ou un
truc comme ça ce qui est ce qui était
très élevé il me semble il fait du coup
elle m'explique que ça s'appelle
hypermnésie parce que sans juste se
baser là-dessus mais je lui rajoute en
fait tout ce que je ressens tout ce que
je t'ai expliqué machin c'est ça a
priori quoi et après j'ai essayé de
faire des recherches mais il n'y a pas
grand chose en fait non parce que peu de
cas c'est toujours la même chose petit
cas peu d'intérêt à étudier le cas du
coup pharmaceutique c'est encore pire il
y a rien à traiter il y a pas de
médicaments à vendre donc pas d'intérêt
par exemple je ça me dit cap pas c'est
un peu lourd des fois et après je veux
pas m'inventer des problèmes non plus tu
vois ce qu'il y avait honte des trucs
plus grave dans la vie mais c'est vrai
que c'est un peu lourdingue des fois
parce que je vais envoyer un message à
quelqu'un si la personne lit mon message
et ne me répond pas déjà je vais bon ça
c'est mon un autre problème c'est que
déjà je vais mal le prendre parce que je
vais me dire j'ai un problème tout ça et
si je dois la recontacter d'ici 5 jours
ou n'importe quoi je vais me dire oui
mais en même temps je lui ai envoyé tel
message elle a pas répondu donc machin
machin et en fait je me souviens aussi
des messages que j'ai envoyé aux gens
enfin tu as des choses comme ça et
peut-être même de l'historique de elle
ça fait trois fois qu'elle m'a pas
répondu direct
tu mets des points tu sais le fait de
digérer nos souvenirs c'est ce qui
permet aussi de temporiser les émotions
les émotions à faites pour être vécue
dans l'instant et pas six mois après si
tu vois ce que je veux dire donc je
pense que cette forme de sensibilité
c'est que tu revis en fait l'impact que
ça t'a donné dans l'instant et ouais
c'est compliqué de le digérer c'est un
souvenir qui se digère pas à la base
dans la mémoire on appelle ça un trauma
tu vois donc c'est comme si tu avais
plein de mini trop bas de vie tu vois
que tu revivais par pétuellement qui
sont ouais c'est ça alors que bon quand
on dit romain en général c'est quelque
chose de lourd et tout moi non ça va
mais c'est vrai que si c'est tout con
mais du repenses à un moment gênant d'y
à 10 ans moi je vais repenser je vais ah
je vais me ressentir comme j'ai ressenti
alors que la personne l'a oublié ou
alors quelque chose de un peu blessant
qu'on m'a dit machin je vais jamais
oublier tout ça moi donc et ça m'arrive
hyper souvent que des trucs vexants on
s'en est tous pris machin et
les autres ils vont dire ça va je rigole
ils me passent à autre chose et moi
c'est je retiens du coup je pense que ça
m'apporte un peu de susceptibilité aussi
sur moi tout mélange ça donne tout
mélanger c'est un peu chiant quoi
parfois du coup tu es rancunier oui
ça dépend en fait je crois que j'ai pas
eu d'occasions de le vérifier de vraies
occasions tu vois genre un vrai drama et
tout on est tous capables de bien
différencier ne serait-ce que par la
sensation à souvenir récent ancien très
ancien ou même de souvenirs anciens on a
plus le contexte et pourtant on arrive à
savoir si il lui avant lui avant lui
est-ce que toi tu as une notion d'
instantanéité est-ce que tes souvenirs
sont tellement précis parfois que ce
serait dur un petit peu de les dater si
t'as pas de référentiel dans le souvenir
pour le dater tu vois ce que je veux
dire ah non bizarrement j'arrive très
bien à dater mes souvenirs tu vois
exemple il y a quelques jours je parlais
d'un moment alors j'étais allée à New
York avec un New York et un ami à moi il
était en même on n'était pas allés
ensemble et on reparlait de ce jour là
et je lui ai dit bam c'était le 22
février 2022 il dit je savais même pas
de la semaine dans la New York comment
tu sais que c'est ce jour-là et en fait
bizarrement je me rappelle juste que
c'était un mardi et je me rappelle qu'on
était parti enfin que moi on a vu on
était parti le 18 donc j'ai fait le
calcul tu vois et je sais en fait c'est
que des petits détails comme ça qui vont
me permettre de resituer
la question que je me pose c'est
pourquoi par exemple je me souviens que
c'était un mardi tu vois parce que j'ai
pas d'éléments qui me permettent de me
dire tiens c'était un mardi j'en ai
aucune idée donc c'est ce genre de truc
et par contre je suis super pratique
quand je veux montrer une photo à
quelqu'un
c'est exactement où elle est pratique
ouais je retiens les dates les moments
de toute façon tout ce qui est chiffre
et date ça c'est fatiguant
cette partie là non ça va mais le reste
je vois les trucs un peu plus négatifs
ouais c'est un peu fatiguant puis les
autres après du coup moi quand je parle
à mes amis quand ça va pas trop et tout
ils sont là tu te poses trop de
questions et tout et ça c'est un peu
douloureux parce que je ne sais mais je
peux pas faire autrement en fait c'est
ça oui c'est qui tu es tu sais pas qui
tu ne dessines c'est qui tue et je
trouve ça dur de dire tu te poses trop
de questions parce que bah en fait je
sais et je peux pas la ranger enfin tu
vois comme si je te disais tu es encore
là dessus ouais c'est ça ouais c'est ça
ça permet aux autres de le comprendre
mais moi il y a un truc c'est genre on
parle je parle à quelqu'un je vais
ressortir telle anecdote et ils vont
dire mais t'es folles de retenir ça
machin il dit ça comme ça pour rire mais
à force que tout le monde te dit tu es
taré tu es folle de retenir ça machin et
tout c'est con mais l'autre fois je dis
que c'est quelqu'un je sais bah oui
c'est bientôt ton anniversaire enfin oui
c'est vrai que toi
en fait les gens ils le prennent pour
eux comme si j'avais un carnet où j'ai
créé une prénom de chaque personne je
leur raconte pas tant d'attention que ça
de regarder un mot et de pas le lire
l'impossibilité de pas absorber cette
information là quoi et du coup Martin je
n'ai pas le droit de louper un
anniversaire quoi
on sait que c'est parce que tu nous en
veux quelque chose qu'on a dit à 8 ans
mais tu sais que le pire c'est qu'en
fait genre tu vas me dire genre du
jardin je vais dire oui il est né le 19
juin mais par contre le 19 juin j'ai pas
forcément me dire ah c'est l'anime de
Jean dujard ça dépend mais en vrai si
quand même mais c'est plus simple dans
l'autre sens tu vois
du jardin par exemple le 10 juin tu vas
dire tiens c'est bientôt son anniv value
et je lui dirai pas parce qu'il va avoir
peur du coup quand tu vis quelque chose
quelque chose n'importe quel émotion
n'importe quel moment tu es dans l'axe
temps présent tu es en train de projeter
dans le futur ou tu es déjà en train de
regarder ce qui va être du passé dans
quelques secondes
j'ai du mal à profiter de l'instant
présent je pense au fait quand je vis un
bon moment je pense au fait que c'est
bientôt fini et je suis déjà triste non
mais c'est horrible c'est par exemple
quand j'ai alors je suis tu l'as dit
tout à l'heure chroniqueuse chez RTL2
j'ai commencé en stage là-bas j'ai
commencé en août 2018 et dès octobre
alors que mon stage devait durer jusqu'à
février 2019 des octobre j'étais c'est
horrible ça va se terminer alors que
c'était il me restait 4 mois et j'étais
déjà triste de quitter mon équipe tout
ça alors peut-être j'ai toujours pas
quitté donc c'est faut que je me détende
quoi tu vois mais c'est un bon exemple
pour te dire que je suis dans l'instant
ouais en gros je au lieu de vraiment de
profiter de l'instant je me dis ah c'est
bientôt fini bientôt Maury très fort
ça va s'arrêter
ta mémoire à court terme tu l'identifies
ou pas attends normal les choses passent
par là avant d'être stockées ailleurs et
moi je pense que s'il y a une petite
déviation dire que si je te donne le
code de ma porte d'entrée je pense que
demain si je te demande le code de ma
pote d'entrée il a tenu tu vois c'est si
je décide de le retenir oui c'est ça
c'est si tu dis tiens c'est important en
fait tu vas accéder tout de suite les
mois à long terme sans trop savoir
pourquoi ni comment mais ça va pas si si
je donne le porte d'entrée à quelqu'un
c'est sûr qu'il va le répéter en boucle
parce que ici pressant que la durée de
vie est de 5 secondes quoi tu vois et ça
c'est incroyable moi je le vois j'ai des
amis qui viennent chez moi ça fait trois
ans qui viennent à chaque fois il me
demande mon code de port toi oui non là
le tien je vais le retenir du coup en
fait toi tu peux tu peux décider de
retenir une donnée facilement pour très
longtemps et ça c'est intéressant parce
que je trouve que ça montre que le les
phrases que l'on envoie à l'inconscient
ça fait marcher la machine aussi tu vois
quand tu es petite et tu te dis je me
souviendrai de cette phrase quand je
serai grand-mère mais tu as tu as envoyé
le truc de ok on fait ça du coup elle on
l'extrait du court terme et on le met
directement dans le long terme comme si
on avait appris mille fois dans notre
vie quoi c'est ça mais je sais pas
pourquoi je sais pas comment bien sûr
est-ce qu'il y a des choses dont tu te
souviens que tu aimerais pouvoir oublier
oui oui ça c'est sûr que c'est je sais
pas pourquoi des fois je j'y repense et
je me mets dans le mal ou même un truc
tous les ans que j'ai fait tu vois c'est
horrible quand tu repenses à un truc
gênant et que la personne en face à
littérale oubliée et c'est donc des fois
je te mets dans des étapes pas possible
en fait pour rien du tout en fait c'est
pas tes souvenirs qui sont épuisants
c'était les émotions c'est mes émotions
et les relier au souvenir du coup fin tu
vois comme les souvenirs restent des
fois c'est un peu lourd d'un quoi je
veux pas m'inventer des problèmes tu
vois c'est juste que c'est des petits
trucs un peu chiants quoi tu as beaucoup
de 17 phrases c'est pas machin mais en
fait il y a pas il y a pas d'échelle
dans les ressentis tu vois ce que je
veux dire que ce que tu ressens ma foi
c'est vrai quoi non mais c'est important
aussi de palier les difficultés ou la
manière que tu as de fonctionner ce qui
peut t'atteindre ce qui peut te et je
pense qu'on a tous conscience que tu es
pas en train de dire victimiser moi ma
vie
est trop dur mais par contre je pense
que à l'issue de cette interview qu'on
aura fait quand même assez facile de se
projeter
un show si quand je repensais à ça
j'avais les mêmes émotions qu'au moment
où j'y étais tu vois moi si je le
repenses à des moments gênants de ma vie
peu en mode ça me tend un peu oui une
seconde et puissance 100 fois moins
forte que à l'époque tu vois par contre
j'imagine que si c'était comme à
l'époque je ouais je j'arrive à toucher
légèrement du doigt ce que tu dois toi
ressentir dans son ensemble et le plus
gros avantage pour toi parce qu'on a pas
beaucoup des inconvénients comme ça mais
après en vrai c'est un peu bête mais ils
vont plus gros avantage c'est aussi mon
plus gros inconvénient c'est à dire que
je peux revivre mes souvenirs donc quand
ils sont heureux c'est génial
DeLorean pour
je pense c'est quand même le plus gros
avantage ce qui est le même que plus
gros inconvénient tout dépend du
souvenir en fait ce que tu sais ce que
tu as fait le 6 avril 2022 le 6 avril
que je débute à stand-up ouais mais là
là c'est marrant parce que je le très
logique du coup d'avoir retrouvé l'info
en mode ça c'était facile ouais je suis
pas sûr que tu disais n'importe qui
d'autre il y a un an tu as annoncé
quelque chose c'est quoi avec la
personne de Facebook c'est facile et par
contre il me souvient de où j'étais
quand j'ai bossé ce truc tu étais où en
fait c'était dans le quartier de Barbès
parce que c'était au Barbès Comedy Club
que j'avais fait et j'étais au Burger
King juste après la dernière question
est-ce que tu vas te rappeler de cette
interview pour toute ta vie mais
forcément me rappeler dans les détails
je pense pas mais je pense que je me
souvenir de quelques petits moments
comme par exemple le code de ta porte ça
dépend de quel fil on tire tu vois moi
je pense que si dans trois ans on dit et
vous aviez déliré sur la date de
naissance d'une personne connue pour moi
je suis persuadé que tu sais qui c'est à
ce moment-là si vous voulez voir aussi
le travail d'arnaque est extrêmement
drôle je vous mets tous les liens dans
la description n'hésitez pas à aller la
suivre quant à moi je suis toujours en
tournée avec mon spectacle si vous
voulez me suivre dans la rue jusqu'à
rentrer dans théâtre vous avez des dates
qui s'affichent le lien est dans la
description activer la cloche parce que
vous avez vu il y a plus de rythme sur
les vidéos elles sortent quand elles
sont prêtes à très bientôt Ciao